[music playing]
NARRATOR: This sea
turtle was found
surrounded by cocaine worth
tens of millions of dollars.
It was spotted by a
US Coast Guard Cutter
in the eastern Pacific Ocean.
The sea turtle was entangled
in lines connecting over two
dozen bundles of cocaine.
[music playing]
The boat crew worked
quickly to cut
the lines that
had become wrapped
around the turtle's neck.
The Coast Guard
recovered 75 feet of line
and 1,800 pounds of cocaine.
The bundles were filled with
an estimated $53 million
of the illegal narcotic.
Sadly, sea turtles
continue to be
killed for their meat and eggs.
They are an endangered species.
[music playing]